here we go this is a second viewing
technically we haven't seen this since
it first came out by intentions of ever
seeing this yeah where we disappointed
this is no has been asked for for a long
time people have asked for this one and
I think it's over like 15 years old now
something like that so we used to be
able to claim it's not nostalgic yeah
now we're older now I know that the
comic wasn't nostalgic in my bed cuz
it's Alan Moore right so I'm not sure
but regardless we have no excuse now so
we got to do it this is League of
Extraordinary Gentlemen I just remember
it being dull as hell and it was from
the dude that did blade and so there was
kind of like well at least be fun cuz I
like blade this is one of our dad's
favorite movies ya know cuz for him it's
entertainingly bad he loves how bad this
movie yeah but I mean but he knows it
shit
so I'm hoping I can give a similar
experience cuz yeah I just remember
being so dull so let's see what made
Sean Connery leave this is League of
Extraordinary Gentlemen aha
so it takes place at a movie studio
Cleopatra really did destroy him didn't
it Wow copperplate gothic font people
last time I saw that was like Batman
return home
whose look Costanza trying to stuff but
trust forgetting the Frogger some
Costanza like you know get out of the
way yeah you dived he won't get past my
pop business oh my god he produced him
Oh Sean
Oh loaded no listen if you mean by put a
deuce I just showed up wrote a check and
then drank out of my flask of scotch
then yes I could adduced it not us is
there that should be more like nine this
is Germany papers back that we're frame
with just tweets not honest
Germany at Germany's speaking English I
see chat we can fill my glass Bruce I
could be the most snobby British thing
possible I'll have a snow be tip I will
have the watery for he's right there
God it's right there of the question is
Ra's al Ghul immortal stories of your
exploits have thrilled English boys for
decades
I was young it was an experimental time
we agreed never to bring that up again
and move like the wind old Sean Connery
I'm sporting only the British conquer a
corner of the globe and talk about other
people being unsporting why can't they
do it the old-fashioned way and just
subjugate these poor people
you missed there was much more him to
hit them now I meant to pin his arm for
his why God shave your show bullshit he
wore glasses yeah in that dusty weather
that probably made him see worse yeah I
could find that he covered was shit
honestly nobody could figure out thats
London well did that building do
something where did you see that no that
would be on below Wow
aren't you a hotshot so what was that
answer me rumor has it that you're a
pirate
rumor has it Disney's gonna make you
white well yeah when haven't they done
that that's probably for the best have
you seen how they do black people that's
the 50s it was a different time
listen we just got done doing Black
Panther way off those sort of jobs
alright things change okay what about
all the blackface we're going to he'll
be much more fun out of this Mickey
Mouse ears he can then this Mickey Mouse
shirt okay so let me just get this
straight is this supposed to be legit or
is this a Mystery Men sequel cuz y'all
look like the mystery men
what in God's name is that I call it
auto movie Doug it's the Leslie special
auto mobile to mobile call me Ishmael
don't bet you know I called my Scottish
tackle Moby Dick
and I imagine me with quite disturbing
covers should try reading books instead
of burning up when I lost parting is
such sweet sorrow
oh so you're nothing more than a minute
okay could you guys say this any less
boring everything you're saying is set
in the most boring way it's like an
interview with the stoned vampire we
were so bored we've decided to interrupt
your conversation yeah Platt hole number
one everyone would laugh like hell
seeing that he looks like some caveman
that just got thought out hedging the
riches just take one look er it's like
oh there's some hot chick under there
I'm sure she's really gonna blow Sean
Connery away Oh what's a dude never mind
well he does the American equivalent
like a kpop star my muscular bastard get
in my six-pack get in my pecs you
underestimate the Nautilus
[Music]
you underestimate her great I'm not
talking okay nevermind I was having the
scene and then you got fuck you this
movie is like Max Rex's power plant from
Batman Returns
it keeps draining it drains more energy
than it puts in writing fascinating
extraordinary gentlemen I want you to
rest on old times
oh there's my boo top garage you know
Sean Connery wrestling with things that
aren't really there and screaming at
them I feel like that's actually
happening right now he wanders around
whatever Scottish Castle he's just doing
man and the servants are just unlike Rob
you're missing the point that scene was
not in the script Sean Connery just did
that and it's like you know I just leave
it in I even took my shine along I even
did my son and lost that what he said a
little bit of God gray gray gray this
movie's more gray than Dorian Gray we're
gonna think movie that shows you what
it's like to be colorblind he must have
told that we were coming nope yeah it's
like the really dangers
damn Skinner they must have told them we
were coming shrug half-smile like I'm in
a movie and making money jump off car
everybody just acts like they're happy
to be getting a paycheck it's like
that's their baseline emotion where is
some vampire chick taking out a bunch of
German soldiers within the army of bad
so that I'm like how could I be this
poor yeah you're put that on paper I
feel right sound so awesome I'm like no
it's really boring
you just look so pathetic of your week
already dead oh you're weak you're weak
as I run away you weak good night Venice
there will be no on course thank God
that is us
you got pee-wee's giant ball up in foil
and I've been true to the girls said to
me why are you showing film if it's a
recording it scratches on the film more
realistic
bones what just dies amazing all going
down together we will be the death of
all of us some great security big out
here wandering around no problem
gonna have to knock out a guy in take
this is I know just walk around like
this guy sounds more like a kid whine to
his mom than like it's a kid in shooter
shooter I'm lost
should anybody know where I am that's
kind of the roly's play give him a gun
and just have him look lost like hello
doc doc you can't kill the future oh I
think this movie's box office results
can yeah bottles of scotch do you think
it took Sean Connery to get through this
double whatever the usual amount is
Damien castle it's salted everything
else do we really now need to have this
kick in the groin to African tradition
because keep a good Scotchman down this
big of a good scotch please somebody get
me one doll as I remember yeah no
connections no chemistry no working on
another movie with the same well like I
said this plot is so tired it was even
tired when this movie was released but
like Atlantis I liked that movie the
Disney movie it's got a bit of a weak
ending but I'm just like that's a melon
that did right he was Creed
they gave it as a steampunk kind of work
not a steampunk shit in this movie was
interesting not it's not even batshit
enough I expect more out of my god I
know we are of shit no we are
connoisseurs of the silly
doll doll boring not interesting that
definitely a ton of material we get out
of it but oh not fun not a fun movie not
a fan so that's it we'll see you next
time later
you